[Music]
the first memories i have as a kid
are the cozy italian sundays with my mom
at the movie theater
my favorite movie of them all was disney
fantasia
i watched lazy mickey mouse trying to
teach that broom how to clean the
sorceress cave and i thought to myself
how incredible it would be if all things
around me could simply come to life
if i could teach them to do all the
things i didn't want to do including
guess what tiding my room
mickey mouse's strategy seemed to be
working out pretty well
the room started cleaning the cave
autonomously and so happy and relieved
mickey simply went to sleep
there was really nothing to worry about
but a few hours later he wakes up to a
completely flooded cave
the rooms had been repeating the same
action over and over again without
realizing what was going on around them
so mickey begged them to stop
but it just won't listen
and so all he could do was tear them
apart
unfortunately a few hours later mickey
quickly realizes it's too late
he has lost control
this time more and more brooms start
invading the cave again desperately
trying to make it more clean
fast forward many years i find myself
often going back to the story as i try
to think about the role of artificial
intelligence in our society
these intelligent algorithms promise to
bring speed efficiency and effectiveness
but ended up making crucial decisions on
our everyday lives
who gets better education better health
care better financial support and who
goes to jail
but just like we don't expect that broom
to understand what we mean by clean
it's up to us to decide and teach those
algorithms what we mean by right
by fair and by good
the thousands of decisions of this kind
are made every day by data scientists
around the world
what data to use what to optimize for
and when a machine learning model is
accurate enough
well i am a data scientist and let me
tell you one thing
you should not trust me
and you should not leave it to
corporations governments or researchers
to make these decisions for you and not
because they intend harm
but because this is not a technology
problem this is a values problem
and i believe all of us should have a
say in the role of ai in our society
and let me show you why
in february 2019 nigeria parks was
arrested
he was accused of shoplifting and trying
to hit a police officer
turns out his face was identified using
a facial recognition software
but after 10 days in jail
the police found out that was a mistake
in august 2020 sharpie row is one of
thousands british students who saw their
college admissions revoked
the uk government had just started using
a new ai tool instead of final exams
that was penalizing struggling schools
in poor areas as opposed to elite
schools in wealthy areas
today
compass is one of the most widely used
ai tools in us criminal justice
so what compass does is it helps judges
determine whether a defendant should be
kept in jail or not while awaiting trial
and it does so by associating a score
from 1 to 10 to each defendant based on
more than 100 personal factors
if this score is high enough that
defendant will be jailed
but analyzing the behavior of this
algorithm showed that biased data coming
in produced biased results going out
let's take vernon and brisha for example
brisha committed minor prior fences and
no subsequent offense
yet as you can see her risk score is
much higher than vernon's
so what does fair mean to us in this
case
does it mean we want to apply the same
criteria to both of them
or does it mean ensuring that they're
both equally likely to be subject to
algorithmic
error because these two definitions are
equally valid but they have a very
different impact on society as a whole
so you see why deciding on rules and on
values it's so hard
because they mean different things for
every one of us
okay i know what you're thinking isn't
that why we elect our decision makers to
make these complex decisions for all of
us
well in theory that's true but the
problem with that is democracy is not
doing that well these days
in the past few years as a youth
activist i have worked hard with the
objective of involving as many young
citizens as possible in the democratic
lives of their communities
and i could see
how democracies are continuing to weaken
institutions appear distant
self-protective unreliable
only one in three americans trust their
elected officials
the political class struggles to
understand the complexity of technology
and to find consensus on the most
divisive matters of our time
we used to think that democracy happens
once every four years in a ballot but it
doesn't have to be this way
researchers and activists have studied a
new model of engagement in the past few
decades
deliberative democracy
and to see what that means let me take
you back to ireland 2015.
80 percent of the irish people approved
gay marriage in a referendum
but that journey started two years
earlier when the irish parliament was
facing a controversial issue for allen's
history and decided it was time to try
something new
so they called a convention on the
constitution composed of 66 ordinary
citizens and 33 members of the
parliament
they came together debated discussed and
some of those recommendations were that
turned into
referendums that became reality
so what happened here
well the world thought these citizens
were just too
polarized
distant and frankly incompetent to have
an impact they actually transitioned
from observers to decision makers
and you can see and you can hear how the
narrative changed from they the policy
makers to we the citizens
just like many activists around the
world that are doing already we can
influence the political agenda by
becoming good lobbyists for the causes
we believe in
deliberative democracy
can happen in many forms citizens
assemblies town halls participatory
budgeting and it has happened everywhere
in the world
from british columbia to kerala from
brazil to denmark from oregon to belgium
in italy politics per casa is trying to
activate the debate on climate change
and in california
citizens assemblies were proposed to
solve the problem of homelessness
i guess what you're thinking
this woman is trying to disrupt
our institutions as we know them for a
new topic direct democracy
couldn't be more wrong
i am suggesting we empower these
institutions every day with active
citizenry
so how can deliberative democracy really
help us design the role of ai in our
society
well first of all we'd have to define
and select a sample of citizens that can
be representative of our diversity
and then we need to set up the process
involve experts secure our decision
makers commitment
and decide the questions we want to
tackle because if we want to design a
new bill of digital rights we'll have to
agree on things like fairness
transparency openness explainability
we'll have to decide how data is
transferred and owned we'll have to
decide who audits who controls who
it will not be an easy process it will
require patience experimentation and
trust in the process even and most of
all when we don't agree with the outcome
but ultimately it'll help us understand
that beyond labels we're simply humans
i am very very passionate about ai i
really believe it can be an incredible
source of good for the world
could ai be the next decision maker
could ai find the best taxation policy
to optimize social welfare
or could we just leave it to ai to solve
climate change
maybe
we just don't know yet
but if and when
ai will be able to find those answers
we'll need to ask the right questions
and when ai will be able to find the
best solutions
we will need to agree on what we mean by
best
all of us should have a say in the role
of ai in our society
now i don't know how many of you have
seen disney fantasia but here's a little
spoiler for you
in the end the sorcerer comes in and
saves the day
but the role of ai in our society is no
mickey mouse game so please stay active
stay informed participate in your
democracy give it one more chance
because this time there will be no
sorcerer coming to save us
this time we cannot afford to go to
sleep
this time we can and we must write the
rules together
[Applause]
[Music]